yeah welcome to this video this will be
a 15-minute game with 10 second
increment you played on icc between my
friend Brandon and Mia's garden the
youtube channel as well and we did on
two of those videos earlier where we
both do a comentary on the same game
played live so you can watch both videos
and compare them thoughts and ideas yeah
we'll have a Queens gambit am an idea
three now and let's see what is playing
um yeah we're playing this on the ICC
because it allows two to choose the time
freely so that dumb play Catalan here so
that we can use ten second increment
better I think then playing without
increment for these games and yeah the
ratings here you can basically ignore it
some- blank I never played this time
control before I play 15 minute in this
pool system where you get a um yeah
about an opponent that the system
chooses one the auto pairing I never
played any games with the challenge
system like him yet to come see for I
just continued development and try to
get this c4 porn later yet Brandon I
think played one or two games with this
time so on his rating is so far far too
low compared to what he will we'll get
them after couple of games he's just new
on icc so c5 is some main line I just
castle here and now nights is 60 and
this position Black has quite some
pressure on the d4 pawn I need to do
something with the deep on now and
though
yeah them down couple of moose Queen a
foursome move dc5 as a move and Knight
e5 as a move 95 is the most oh yeah
maybe the most aggressive move I think
that's also night a three think and a
camera recently played this against
kyden off but I don't know it I don't
know the line d takes d5 use really
needs to a slide where it slide end game
advantage after takes on d 1 rupee one
Bishop c5 not VD 2 and then C 3 a chance
upon I think I'll play 95 this is some
yeah maybe the most aggressive move and
I'm not sure that Brandon knows the
theory really so he needs to thank him
the need idea or one of the ideas of
this move is that night XD for Lewis
immediately due to e3 and yeah the night
is attacked and if it retreats you can
exchange on d 8 and then night f seven
wins the rook or III 96 you could just
capture them and win at least the
exchange so night XD form instantly
loses the game on like some normal movie
as Bishop to d7 he can also take on e5
but this is some considered to be M
comfortable for white this pawn on d5 is
just very disturbing for black white is
got the brilliant bishop on g2 and the
c-4 point you will get them back almost
immediately with night a three so Bishop
d7 is some by farm for the main move him
yeah he doesn't know that that line so
we need to figure it out himself yeah
very often not players who don't know it
take on e5 don't play Bishop d7 on
Bishop d7 I will play on I to a 3 and
then take on c4 with the a39 so night aw
793 see takes d4 Knight takes e4 and
white is ready to recapture on e5 with
the new nightie appearing on c4 then it
usually continues Bishop c5 we should
perform queen bee three group to f1 fd1
Roxy one yeah as I as I as I guessed he
decided to take it yeah now black gown
can choose between taking on d1 or
playing 97 immediately from 97 or 95
year this is also possible um so on what
should I play now one ideas some a move
that needs to be checked nonetheless as
he formed attacking the night but it
would blunt the bishop I would destroy
his castling right take on da peeking
yet but playing if I was just with this
Bishop and move you yeah you don't
really want to play so im- better must
consider
other ideas him yeah not a three-year
some certainly possible trying to get
the porn back at some yeah he could
cover it with 96 but this would be
immensely time consuming all night a
three he could also play C 3 but also um
yeah this seems far far too slow yeah I
tried to get the palm back this way
getting quickly to to c4 with the nidus
sir is quite nice yes III now looks
really risky I think I would um just
take okay decided to continue with some
development very sensibly so just takes
on c4 do i do I have some some other
great idea don't think so I'll take it
yeah I think black should castle now
they don't see em another move really if
it doesn't cancel our appt 596 let's say
b5 it looks insane but let's just to
check it be 5 i'll go on lighter yeah i
could also play 93 but 96cm takes pawn
takes and you cannot take with the Queen
because of Ethier evo when Sir the night
I'm just threatening 96 now it's time to
sing a piece down the porn if you would
take a take with the pawn and that will
play you for 95 this would be terrible I
think him yeah he must castle if i play
96 then then there might be other ideas
because it's another check he can maybe
try to you has somehow evict this night
okay he just canceled young 96 is not
them not out of this world I still
wonder if I have some ideas related to
this night position one problem that
black often faces in the schedule and
structures that he doesn't have a really
good square for the Queen the Queen
could go to see sevens about the only
yeah decent square I'm thinking about
them queen bee three at the moment
between v3r up g1 something along these
lines the some looks pretty decent
queen bee three will also prevent be
five for the moment any beep on move and
I'm Ruby one hour threatening fossil
that he most probably needs to go to see
seven yeah blacks position is somewhat
passive but it is solid okay so I do
that don't want to think agency em yeah
I must them again apologize for the
bottle noise but if I don't drink
something in this 30 minutes of the game
I would most likely lose consciousness
yeah so what should black do now he
could sort of prophylactically move the
Queen away to c7 where it might need to
go anyway b6 could be an idea try to
play Bishop d7 but after up d1 you're
pretty much forced to play Quincy seven
and i'm not sure you want to do that
okay it seems to still entertain the
idea of playing be five I see
so should i still play work g one I mean
b5 is not a threat as the rock um is
hanging on be eight so rock b1 b5 reform
um some valid option yeah it needs to go
to the one anyway I think and b5 I could
also play just 93 probably okay so it
cannot really go p5e for is threat now
Quincy 7am Quincy 7i think must be must
be played now or I mean I'm not
threatening anything at the moment
besides you for of course um what I want
to say is that maybe he can also play
Bishop d7 but it looks so looks very
weird
yeah Quinn sees em looks just like the
normal move yeah and what should i do on
cootie seven I cannot see i plated I
cannot really am really go for Bishop
takes d5 this is insane takes rook takes
we should be six and downloads material
with p5 to come yeah the normal normal
muth here would be a form preventing be
fine for the moment and then after that
see how to continue I still wander bad
I'm stop thinking about eform eform
night moves and then night to d6 if this
is not an option 96 we should have for
supporting this this piece on d6 or
should I really play an e for a a phone
sorry a for preventing the beep on move
yes I still feel I should do that which
five looks really really annoying
if you play some B 6 now which would be
a normal idea then maybe 96 is an idea
also attending night to be five
harassing the Queen 96 was some even an
idea when instead of four but it looks
you know it looks a bit premature not
sure what it is really doing on d6 yeah
b6 hmm I could do a slow move Bishop d
to sort of threatening e-form I could
could play you for immediately I could
play night 36 quite some quite some
choice
come on let's do 96cm if everything else
fails i still can't take on 78 and get
two bishops yeah of course if he takes
t6 now should be six ed six community
634 and I window in the night I think I
hope that's not no no no there is no
trick is briefly thinking there might be
some some trick yeah what would be in
the normal response to this move and one
thing I'd consider would be Bishop a6
attacking the poem but i would have
night be fire fires and as a known as a
good reply after which the Queen doesn't
have a really good square to go wet
still covers the a7 pawn and what now be
five is some an idea anyway so I'm i
hope this move has its annoying for for
black one ideas also to play probably at
some point Bishop d2 and then you form
after which the default five light
doesn't have fun it doesn't have a
square I'm really
yeah it's a difficult a difficult
position for black it's not obvious what
what active moves you could play yeah be
sure basics hmm yeah that's um another
interesting idea for black Nerissa it's
the move c5 to see form which is maybe a
possibility but I think I'm night would
be 54 must be a good move really well
why should the Queen go now Queen D
seven runs into e-form Queen c6 I just
take a seven and Queen B seven is in the
middle in this long diagonal and it just
looks terrible I don't see a direct
refutation at the moment but it's
certainly had certainly bad for black
Queen to be seven even look takes d5
might be right be feasible yeah rook
takes d5 ed 555 and it's a huge
compensation Queen d7 then a successor
is winning the Arab t5 looks looks
terrible so I'm okay I can hmm can I
kind of just take a seven now I mean I'm
not saying that you had anything better
but i think i can take it yeah I guess
so I'll just take the pawn and retreat
with a night if you texted in a way I
just I just drop it back end half an
extra porn
I don't think he can play something like
Wincy 795 Queenie five because of takes
on d5 and Bishop f4 once the exchange
maybe that's maybe there's some even
something better but um there should be
enough to to hinder into this idea yeah
but where should he go Queen d7 yeah
I'll retreat yeah he tries to get onto
this pawn ok let's drop this back and
detect the Queen if he takes d5 now
there's also oops no this was a mall
slip yeah he's got trouble with the
small talk me that before I needs to get
a new one mm-hmm we wanted to take on
you five obviously I'll send the tape
back
yeah yeah do it take back the signals
except yeah this is just a Muslim Andy
he really has got this problems with
this cell with his mouth so no big deal
we'll continue continue from here so
what now why body form if always the
normal looking move driving the night
away and then playing Bishop f4 winning
the exchange on be aid the only question
is if I play you for what kind of
possible intermediate moves does he have
something like c4 for example but then I
can I think just move the Queen away to
to ask where we're isn't detect
immediately like f3 or something yeah
there must be correct it must be correct
so c4 okay c4 I could also just take
wouldn't be wouldn't be terrible i think
but then he would have robbed c8 gaining
a tempo and saving the exchange so once
you file I'd like to move the Queen to
the safe safe Graham I only wonder what
might happen let's say C for Queen f3
night before Bishop f4 and queen txp to
this might be slightly irritating is not
on before the see pollen see files
giving away the beach upon
I'm not too sure that this is so great
yeah anyways he falls the only move to
post me any kind of problem I think but
maybe I should just take it yeah I
should just take it this is much simpler
i guess i will take the pawn on c4 let's
say rook c8 22 and after the light moves
anywhere before something I played nada
Bishop f4 okay didn't place your phone
okay this was the idea anyway but c4 I
can take I think this is better than any
Queen move yeah now I'm black screen as
exactly 1 nano two squares this one also
so just take it or is there is there
something else so according to Larry
Christian Christensen's rule if you see
a good move look for a better move I'm
not sure that I agree to that really if
you say good move it's often a good idea
to play it yeah if you see a good move
look for a better move with this cradle
but okay I cannot catch the Queen the
Queen doesn't have much square so you
could really think about them some
trapping trapping mechanisms but there
is nothing to to trap the Queen i think
ii five Queen g6 and I cannot attack it
so I grab the grab the rope here the
exchange so I'm a Kleenex changeup how
do i how do I win this now
yeah does he have any any counterplay
really not at the moment it's all nicely
coordinated what should I play thinking
about rook t7 really it looks on it
prepares w on the D file and it
threatens if 5v5 foot window is having
bishop basically so root is Sam it's
certainly not bad glad this day and
don't I hope I'm not blundering they
look or something but at least I looks
like a decent idea if black does our
nothing moves now I'll play you five and
wendy is having bishop
here maybe something like lie to Knight
to c6 if this is playable not entirely
sure black's pieces are bit yeah a bit
strangely tied together yeah what not
sure what life should do now how to get
any kind of compensation for the
exchange what you would love to do is
the yeah then the seven bishop this
would somehow we will be possible to
somewhat activate this piece it would be
entirely different okay so II five which
really weakens the the whites of the
light squares in this position looks
pretty weakening 9725 it's a it's an
idea okay but maybe just just loop you
one first I want the idea what this move
what I was trying to say only is that
the c7 Bishop was the problem if it
would be active let's say on deform not
very realistic that black would manage
to a white black or manage to do that
but this would be really entirely
different okay so let's say rook 81
maybe he goes Bishop c8 then and i'm not
sure where where all this is leading
97 is also an option might have seen
might have c4 then who okay I think
maybe I should play Bishop to f1 with
the idea of going bishops you form the
bishop is not doing much on g2 really
and it would be much better on on c4 and
if he goes Bishop f1 if he goes Bishop
c8 I would retreat the rock and on
Bishop e6 I can play em Bishop c4 maybe
hmm yeah this could be a good idea the
only issue of getting the Bishop to c4
that my king position looks looks really
weak
hmm yeah I'm not sure it's not um I
don't need to play this immediately but
Bishop c8 it's a problem if I retreat
the rock this [ __ ] would be six move as
Sam it's really annoying of course
that's also night c7 okay this um this
look on these have been doing anything
good anyway in this disposition or
should I just move it away
prophylactically night c7 doesn't bring
bring anything because of Bishop see aid
hmm here really somewhat difficult but I
don't see what you can do really to my
king position okay I'll drop this back
and go Bishop Bishop to c4 after this
Bishop c8b should be six maneuver still
I need to be careful too if I remove
this this piece from the Kings side one
thing that I always have to keep in mind
is to get to possibly return the
exchange at the proper moment because
the light squares that black am has just
weakened with you five would guarantee
me am a pretty nice advantage anyway so
let's say he moves Bishop c8 then I
would treat the rook but if I would just
play rook d1 we turn into the exchange
with Bishop e7 luke t seven this would
be rather nice for me because Bishop c4
would come attacking f7 the rookies on
the seventh I have a nice night only
five he's got us
we had a position piece on before but
the differences in the bishops my bishop
on c4 would be in any case much stronger
than the e7 bishop so I'm bishop CA drew
khod one is not not not bad at all I
hope okay he intends to immediately go
to d4 with the night yeah this was some
was an idea of course as well so if you
go snotty for I can I can just take it
somehow I know this whole position it
looks a little bit shaky for black hello
the a6 bishop assam is unprotected
hmm so should I just um just go on
Bishop c4 then night to a5 it's just
nonsense gypsy 494 just take it okay
yeah I need to get them get going here
this put some pressure on f7 possible
idea could be roped d1 d3 f3 just
attacking the spawn I didn't see any of
any big knockout all right so how should
I take now maybe da porn which would
immediately open up the DEA file yeah
must be good night 85s sir as mentioned
just just just nonsense he will go to
deform he cannot attack the rook with
the Queen which is very reassuring that
this won't happen yeah must be fine 94 i
can i can go basically any way anywhere
with the Queen he just has a check on f3
and rook 12 a7s serve as my next move
pretty much whatever is he's doing our
play this ok this is rhodium white
square looks just okay covering
everything and neither 3s um it's just a
check I hope night a three King g2 and
not much happening
yeah in fact if you play some sort of
zero move now you cannot move much
anyway okay this one yeah should I take
it or look 1287 rock 1287 looks or maybe
take a true k7k let's get this first I
don't need to hurry and maybe just Kim G
to young overprotecting f3 so we will
never be able to to give this check rook
a7 now or look aah ok seminole looks
good attacking f7 so we should be set
now pretty much the only only move yeah
and how do I make progress than wow
really this is a net doses so we had
move ok it seemed not working
technically what you never can exchange
this night this is the only hope he
needed to go boo should be said but I
think it's just loses technically now
takes c6 and Queen takes I just take the
aid and to take UCL rupiah a eight
should win the bishop yeah I'm picking
up the bishop now yeah but even
strategically you cannot go 96 in this
position you need to keep the slap
resins their phone black needs to play
play this year it should be seven and
then it's it's not so I mean white is
winning okay but I still need to do some
sub tactic technical
some technical work how would it start
probably probably something like this
and black is very tied up yeah like
cannot move much is the problem you
cannot move this this Bishop because of
the threats on f7 and this night is
nicely positioned but it doesn't have a
move and that will try slowly to improve
the position maybe with the possible F
form at some point Queen moves a form
also one problem could be that if I give
this check let's say I'm I don't know
what black should play really sum 0 move
let's say something like this I can I
can go here with this idea and this wins
instantly yeah I think in a pretty
interesting game thanks for watching and
make sure also to check the black some
the black players version of the
comentary i'll post the link in the
description and yeah it's always
interesting to compare those two
commentary's yeah thanks and talk to you
soon with new videos